[Música]
continúan las evacuaciones de
extranjeros y afganos desde el
aeropuerto de kabul bajo el control
militar estadounidense pero con los
accesos vigilados por el grupo talibán
francia italia alemania australia y
reino unido son los países que suman
esfuerzos para evitar una crisis
humanitaria mayor en ese país
los fenómenos naturales no le dan
respiro a haití cuatro días después de
que el terremoto de magnitud 7.2
acudiera el sur del país la tormenta
tropical reid afectó las tareas de
rescate complicando las con las fuertes
lluvias miles de personas continúan sin
hogar y los hospitales se encuentran
completamente colapsados
[Música]
entró en vigor en cuba la primera ley de
ciberseguridad se trata de una normativa
que tipifica como delito difundir
noticias que desprestigian al país este
texto llega un mes después de las
masivas protestas en la isla que
alcanzaron una mayor difusión de la mano
de las redes sociales
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco como siempre
un gusto acompañarlos y comenzamos en
afganistán donde los países occidentales
continúan sus labores de evacuación de
sus ciudadanos y también de
colaboradores las ganas de kabul tras la
toma del país por parte del grupo
talibán esto tras una relativa calma que
se vive en el aeropuerto internacional
de la capital afgana luego del caos
vivido el día lunes es donde murieron al
menos seis personas el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón anunció que
cerca de 200 afganos que trabajaron con
el gobierno de su país fueron evacuados
junto con ciudadanos franceses lo propio
hizo el gobierno alemán que continúa su
esfuerzo para sacar a sus connacionales
y colaboradores de ese país y por su
parte reino unido- evacuado hasta ahora
a 306 ciudadanos británicos y dos mil 52
afganos según lo informó en el
parlamento el primer ministro boris
johnson quien también aseguró que espera
convocar en los próximos días una
reunión virtual del g7 para abordar la
crisis en ese país
y también crearemos rutas seguras
legales para que los afganos más
necesitados vengan y se establezcan aquí
en el reino unido así que además de los
afganos con los que hemos trabajado
directamente puedo anunciar hoy que nos
comprometemos a reubicar a otros cinco
mil afganos este año con un nuevo plan
de reasentamiento a medida centrado en
los más vulnerables en particular las
mujeres y los niños y lo mantendremos en
revisión en los próximos años con el
potencial de acoger hasta 20 mil a largo
plazo como dating up to trick y fans
agro launcher para entender más sobre la
importancia geopolítica de afganistán
conectamos con patricio giusto él es
consultor político docente universitario
y director de diagnóstico político
observatorios y no argentino patricio
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 muy buen día para usted para
josep borrel el jefe de la diplomacia la
unión europea' la toma de afganistán por
parte del talibán es uno de los eventos
geopolíticos más importantes de los
últimos años en todo el mundo le
pregunto por qué
bueno en primer lugar por la ubicación
histórica que ha tenido afganistán en el
corazón de asia central en gracia
central y medio oriente siempre ha sido
una ruta de paso el comercio de la red
de infraestructura de la región y
siempre una región conflictiva
ingobernable y inaccesible en términos
geográficos nosotros de las
características y casi 30-40 años de
inestabilidad política desde la invasión
soviética del 79 para acá después una
guerra civil de 15 años preocupación
estadounidense ha sido punto neurálgico
y conflictivo de la región ahora
patricia de países como usted bien lo
hacía como rusia irán o china que ya
tienen alguna especie de nexo con el
talibán cuáles son los intereses de
estas naciones en afganistán yo creo que
el principal interés se ha hablado mucho
y yo creo que más bien desde posiciones
ideológicas yo creo que el principal
interés de todas las naciones de la
región es la estabilidad es el orden la
estabilidad y que va a afganistán no se
convierta duran más en el principal
santuario del terrorismo
tengamos en cuenta que es un país que en
su totalidad ha sido tomado con un grupo
fundamentalista que históricamente ha
refugiado a los terroristas esto le
preocupa china esto le preocupa rusia
los intereses económicos de estos países
son relativamente escasos más bien
incluso la india también tendríamos que
sumar e irán más bien el interés
principal de todos estos países
potencias regionales es el orden la
estabilidad y que permitan en que en
afganistán a partir de ahora no prospere
masivamente el prodi si es que
precisamente usted ya lo mencionaba y
frente a este escenario diferente al
temor de que afganistán se convierta
entonces en un refugio para el
terrorismo será el país un escenario de
división entre las potencias
occidentales y naciones como china o
rusia y otras yo creo que es una pena y
probablemente quede en una vereda de los
eeuu con esta retirada y esta ocupación
de 20 años fallida en el marco del
conflicto con china no sobre todo quede
como en una verdad quizás china
supuestamente sosteniendo al talibán con
rusia y con otros aliados y los eeuu
esto es una visión realmente que va a
conducir a que la situación solamente
empeore porque es imposible imaginar que
afganistán en algún momento cercano se
estabilice sin la cooperación de eeuu
china rusia india y otras potencias
regionales y que es probablemente es
probable que esto que decís suceda pero
sería una pena porque eso le daría
empeorar la situación en afganistán e
incertidumbre de un difícil escenario
entonces geopolítico muchísimas gracias
patricio por su tiempo y por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 nosotros
continuamos y nos vamos ahora hasta
haití cuatro días después de que un
terremoto de magnitud 7.2 acudiera el
sur de ese país dejando al menos 1000 4
941 muertos y 9 mil 900 heridos la
tormenta tropical grace dificulta aún
más las labores de búsqueda y rescate de
supervivientes debido a las fuertes
lluvias las precipitaciones fueron
intensas lo que ha afectado directamente
a la cerca de 136 mil 800 familias que
se han quedado sin techo por los daños
registrados por este terremoto
catalogado como el segundo más mortífero
de los últimos 25 años en américa
latina' más temprano conectamos con
puerto príncipe con nuestro periodista a
coche un pie
os contó cómo se ha repartido la ayuda
internacional a las zonas más afectadas
y esto fue lo conocido
bueno a
varios países empresas
presentes en el terreno como bolivia y
vemos como colombia venezuela y canadá
sobre todo eeuu que lleva mucha
capacidad para llevar personales y
productos en el terreno eso es muy
importante porque la prioridad para la
gente nos han dicho que es la agua
comida carpas y antisépticos y hasta
ahora pudieron llevar desde zonas
difíciles hasta 4 principio más o menos
guarden las personas heridas gravemente
y también la buena noticia es que
pudieron sacar
34 personas extraídas de los escombros
y vamos a cuba donde entró en vigor su
primera ley de ciberseguridad es una
norma que tipifica como delitos la
difusión de noticias que tengan un
impacto desprestigio para el país o que
alteren el orden público no se explica
juan pupiales
divulgación de difamación con impacto en
el prestigio del país el agro ciudad
alta promover la indisciplina social
peligrosidad muy alta son algunos de los
incidentes tipificados como delitos en
la primera ley de ciberseguridad de
scuba son en total 17 delitos que van
desde la propagación de noticias falsas
hasta el terrorismo o la ciberguerra a
mí me parece que eso es algo en contra
de la libertad de expresión de cada cual
me entiendes y en otros países lo hacen
no sé por qué aquí no nos lo prohíben me
parece que eso está mal
un texto que para el gobierno se trata
de un marco legal en un territorio que
dio la bienvenida el internet móvil
apenas en 2018 y esta resolución de
nuestro ministerio lo que establece es
ir a la posibilidad o amplía la
posibilidad de trabajar ante cualquier
incidente debe sin excesiva seguridad
pero desde human rigths watch de la mano
de su director para las américas josé
miguel vivanco crítica en que la ley
restringe el acceso a internet
[Aplausos]
y es que la norma llega a poco más de un
mes después de unas protestas en las que
miles de personas marcharon en rechazo
al gobierno consideradas como una de las
manifestaciones más importantes en los
últimos años dichas movilizaciones
terminaron con un muerto decenas de
heridos y cientos de arrestados además
de un apagón del internet durante cinco
días
esta ley entra en vigor una semana
después de que el senado de eeuu
respaldar al gobierno de washington para
que prestará servicios de internet a la
isla algo que el ejecutivo cubano
califica como una injerencia
y a continuación repasemos los incendios
que siguen activos en europa y eeuu
comenzamos en francia donde una persona
murió y 27 más resultaron heridas en la
localidad de grimaux tras el incendio
que afecta desde el lunes a una
ampliación al macizo de los son moros
junto a la costa azul y que sigue
avanzando
los bomberos continúan este miércoles
luchando contra un gran incendio
forestal
descontrolado en una zona montañosa al
noroeste de atenas que ha arrasado ya
unas 8000 hectáreas en las últimas dos
semanas grecia se ha visto sacudida por
una serie de incendios sin precedentes
en eeuu altix y fire continúa ardiendo
en el norte de california hasta ahora ha
quemado más de 253.000 hectáreas desde
que comenzó hace seis semanas
actualmente sólo está contenido en 31%
los expertos se reiteran en la temporada
de incendios forestales es debido al
cambio climático
vamos ahora a eeuu o seguimos más bien
donde la variante delta ha vuelto a
elevar la situación epidemiológica a los
niveles previos al inicio de la campaña
de vacunación la semana pasada el país
registró casi un millón de casos y cerca
de 5.000 muertes una situación que
desespera el personal sanitario que
lamenta la polarización de la gestión
del virus el informes de rosa pérez
mateu
una puerta de las que sólo se abren a
los vacunados para entrar en locales de
ocio de la ciudad de nueva york ya es
obligatorio haber recibido al menos una
dosis del fármaco contra el hobbit 19
las dos estamos vacunadas siento que es
una forma más segura de venir me siento
bastante bien al respecto
una medida orientada a frenar la
variante delta que está causando un auge
de contagios diarios a escala nacional
equiparable a los niveles de diciembre
cuando apenas había empezado la campaña
de vacunación el rebrote de contagio se
está desencadenando en un repunte de las
hospitalizaciones sobre todo en los
estados con niveles más bajos de
inmunización es el caso de arkansas
donde los médicos se declaran exhaustos
medios es muy frustrante muchos de
nosotros yo incluida sentimos que esto
no debería estar pasando con la vacuna
disponible lo que lo hace muy duro el
personal médico constata la alerta
lanzada por las autoridades la
polarización política de la respuesta a
la pandemia
combatimos la desinformación y nos
peleamos los unos con los otros mientras
deberíamos luchar juntos contra el virus
el virus debería ser el problema y una
de las caras de la polarización es el
gobernador de texas greg abbott el
republicano dio positivo en kobe 19 y
persiguen la justicia a los distritos
tec sanos que siguen la recomendación
federal de exigir el uso de las
mascarillas dentro de las aulas una
medida que también intentó prohibir ron
de santis el también republicano
gobernador de florida el estado más
afectado por la pandemia por lo que a
una semana del inicio de clases todavía
no está claro si los estudiantes deberán
o no usar el tapabocas
así las cosas en eeuu debido a la
pandemia de co bit 19 seguimos en
nuestro continente pero venimos hasta el
sur el gobierno peruano a la cabeza del
presidente pedro castillo afronta su
primera crisis luego de que el canciller
héctor béjar dejará el cargo por unas
polémicas declaraciones sobre terrorismo
y la armada peruana dejar solo estuvo en
el cargo 19 días veamos el informe
tras sólo 19 días en el cargo y en medio
de la presión del congreso y de las
fuerzas armadas del perú renunció el
ministro de relaciones exteriores héctor
béjar la causa las declaraciones
polémicas que hizo en el febrero de 2020
que resurgieron recientemente porque el
terrorismo en el perú lo inició la
marina y esto se puede demostrar
históricamente y han sido entrenados
para eso por la cia
finalmente las declaraciones desataron
una ola y protestas de los militares
peruanos
[Música]
acerca de la marina guerra del perú la
marina siempre ha sido honesta el
exguerrillero héctor béjar fue quien
fundó el ejército de liberación peruano
en el año 1962 época en la que logró
conocer a ernesto ché guevara en cuba
con 85 años su llegada al gabinete de
gobierno desató la polémica desde el
primer día abiertamente de izquierda
radical nunca escondió sus nexos con
vladimir cerrón el líder y fundador del
partido marxista perú libre pero el
descontento de los peruanos no se acaba
ahí si héctor béjar estaba en la mira
antes de las revelaciones de sus
declaraciones también lo está el primer
ministro guido bellido investigado por
terrorismo con sus supuestos nexos con
los remanentes del grupo sendero
luminoso pero también por lavado de
dinero en la supuesta financiación
ilícita de su campaña unas polémicas que
disminuyen las posibilidades de que gane
el voto de confianza del congreso
votación programada para el 26 de agosto
y de esta manera finalizamos nuestro
informativo en france 24 continúe con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buen día y hasta pronto
[Música]
siga todas las noticias del deporte con
france24 todas las imágenes todas